en su discurso inauguración Luis
michiguabo tenía un mensaje que
transmitir el nombre de África el
continente se siente abandonado por los
occidentales muy concentrados en Ucrania
para mostrar su malestar la jefe de la
organización Internacional de la
francofonía no dice ni una palabra sobre
la guerra en Ucrania
en nuestro mundo fracturado la
francofonía debe seguir siendo un
vínculo un foro privilegiado para el
diálogo
constantemente en alerta para evitar que
las tensiones se generen en conflictos
la francofonía en el mundo son 321
millones de hablantes 32 países han
hecho el francés su lengua oficial la
mayoría de ellos En el continente
africano también es la quinta lengua más
hablada del mundo y la tercera en el
mundo de los negocios pero el magreb y
África subsahariana está en declive el
francés a menudo se asocia con la
colonización
en los países del magreb el francés se
habla menos que hace 20 o 30 años eso es
una realidad
a veces debido a formas de resistencia
política y a un deseo de rehabilitar
otras lenguas
pero creo que hay que tener un proyecto
detrás un proyecto
una reconquista que pasa en primer lugar
por un acuerdo firmado este sábado entre
París y túnez en concreto un préstamo de
200 millones de euros para reforzar la
enseñanza del francés en el país magrebí
en 2050 gracias a la demografía africana
750 millones de personas hablarán
francés la lengua de moliere parece
tener un brillante futuro por delante